jean-claude beaujour merci c'est d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france alors avec la crise en
afghanistan beaucoup s'interrogent sur
la politique d'accueil des réfugiés
afghans aux états unis le chef d'état
français en tête puisqu'il a déclaré
dimanche dernier dans les colonnes du
jdd je le cite quand les américains
disent qu'ils ont exfiltré temps de
milliers de personnes ce ne sont pas des
afghans qu'ils accueillent directement
sur leur seul américain on en a vu
arriver en europe alors est ce que c'est
le cas comment ça s'est passé
alors tout d'abord c'est vrai que deux
chiffres qui est intéressant puisque
visite environ 50 mille afghans pour
être passé de l'afghanistan vers les
états unis alors qu'à l'époque du
vietnam il y en avait trois cent mille
voyais bien qu'il y avait une différence
et déjà des voix s'étaient élevées
contre l'administration byden certains
lui reprochaient de ne pas avoir
diligenté suffisamment
l'examen du statut des des afghans des
âniers finalement de des états unis et
des pays européens qui étaient en
afghanistan qui ont aidé les occidentaux
lorsque ceux ci étaient en afghanistan
pour pouvoir les rapatrie donc on leur
reproche était déjà faire
l'administration baden de ne pas faire
suffisamment à partir du moment où on
savait que la présence militaire
américaine
serait arrêtée dans les conditions que
nous connaissons et bien que tout devait
être mis en oeuvre beaucoup plus
rapidement le deuxième le deuxième
élément c'est qu'il faut bien savoir
dans cette affaire par rapport à aa
l'histoire vietnam vietnam ou
américaines et l'opinion publique à a
beaucoup changé aux états unis
aujourd'hui les états unis considèrent
qu'ils n'ont plus à être le gendarme du
monde et que par voie de conséquence il
n'est pas question qu'il y avait une
sorte de deux portes ouvertes à tous
donc oui il y à une gauche américaine la
gauche du parti démocrate qui rappelle
les obligations des états unis qui a des
voix morale qui s'élèvent aussi pour
dire on nous a aidés à commencer par
le secrétaire d'état à la défense
d'austin qui a rappelé qu' il y allait
de l'obligation de morale des etats unis
d'aider ceux qui les ont aidés lors ce
qu'ils étaient en afghanistan
pour autant on voit bien que tout ça se
fait avec beaucoup de prudence la vérité
plus prête à recevoir qui pendent sans
contrôle et donc elle le fait savoir une
administration baden traduit en quelque
sorte véritablement sur le terrain cet
état d'esprit nouveau américain ce qui
est effectivement en
1982 je baille donnent à leurs sénateurs
avaient co présenter une loi pour
augmenter les quotas de réfugiés
accueillis chaque année louis jo bayonne
il a aussi évolué sur cette question
à l'époque était sénateur ces deux
spécialistes de questions
internationales souvenez-vous
nous étions tous beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus jeune mais le service au
vietnam et été faits de guerre qui
valorisait le moindre américains parce
que l'amérique à cette époque avec ce
sentiment qu'il avait une mission
universelle d'une mission internationale
y avait d'ailleurs eu deux textes aux
états unis le texte sur indochine
migration en faveur des réfugiés de 1975
et par la suite un autre texte sur les
réfugiés en 1990 on voit bien qu'il y
avait une philosophie politique qui
était différente à l'époque il fallait
lutter contre le communisme à
l'extérieur aujourd'hui il y a le sait
le terrorisme qui a remplacé en quelque
sorte cette lutte contre le communisme
tout en sachant qu'il ne faut pas rêver
aussi une chose c'est que certains
disent que ce sont des habitants que par
mieux pour y avoir des terroristes parmi
eux il pourrait y avoir
un certain nombre de musulmans radicaux
ont envoyé la question religieuse
s'invite aussi dans ce débat même si les
sous jacents donc on voit bien que de
joe biden aujourd'hui est pris par cela
sa réalité politique parce que n'oubliez
pas que dans un an il a des élections de
mi mandat et est donc ça s'il a
vraisemblablement tête ce qui n'était
pas son cas lorsqu'il était sénateur
lorsqu'il siégeait comme sénateur allait
porter de la fin de la guerre du vietnam
et est ce que cette question de
l'accueil des réfugiés afghans en europe
et aux états unis
finalement elle ne risque pas de tendre
les relations entre les alliés entre
l'union européenne et les etats unis si
les américains ne prennent pas
suffisamment leurs parents tout cas d'un
point de vue européen
alors certainement oui parce que
souvenons nous il a de la guerre nous
nous sommes à quelques jours du 11
septembre souvenez vous c'est le
président
le président bush george bush qui avait
décidé après les attaques du
11-septembre d'aller faire la guerre
dans cette partie du monde et donc qui
avait incité des européens
dont la france a les ferrière et donc
être présent donc des fraudes et les
européens en tout cette remarque
aujourd'hui en disant nous vous avons
suivi pour un certain nombre d'entre
nous vous avez décidé d'aller faire la
guerre aux motifs prix qu'il fallait
lutter contre l' état islamique
et maintenant vous prenez pas tout tout
autre part de responsabilité dans ce
conflit je pense que oui ça peut être un
sujet d'envergure en tout cas un sujet
de tension fort entre
bruxelles ou paris et washington parce
que là on aurait eu un comportement
qu'on comprendrait par le côté on dit on
va faire la guerre puis d'un côté on ne
prend pas toutes ses responsabilités
d'ailleurs vous voyez bien qu'un certain
nombre de gens disent et c'est ça paraît
dans votre reportage ce qu'il faudrait
c'est que les migrants dans reste qu'on
est plutôt les états voisins avec
lesquels il aurait une proximité
culturelle beaucoup plus fort on aime
ses états voisins allez allez recevoir
voyez bien qu'il y arriver à une
discussion à géométrie extrêmement
variable avec des intérêts qui sont
repas est absolument identique donc dans
quelques semaines nous aurons en tout
état cause des discussions etats unis
europe france mais aussi les pays de la
sous région
du sous-continent
aide aux pakistanais
un grand merci jean claude beaujour pour
votre éclairage ce matin sur rtl france
je le rappelle vous êtes avocat
vice-président de france amérique